Ngoài nơi mùa thằng tám năm 2018, công an thành phố Chí Minh đang tạm giữ vỏ bá thành.
Xin năm 2018, một thành phố Chí Minh để đưa tra về hành viết người.
Thành lần như phạm rất hay Chí Hát, Xin năm 2018, một hình trở lách tình biên trẻ của
Né là tình viện lòng.
Rồi dấu thi thế nả nhân vào trong phá lý và đặt tại con hệm của Chín Đường Su vít Nye Tính,
phong thận Mỹ Tây, thành phố Chí Minh.
Mưa đầu, thành hay, có quan hệ tình cảm với Chí Hát và cả 2 cùng cơm đứng bẩm xin.
Trời nơi hơi 2 tháng 7 năm 2018,
Chí Hát đến nhà thành trong hệm su vít nye tính trời, rồi sẻ ra mô thống,
thành tình cộng khiến lạnh nhất từ vòng.
Với ăn sông, thành địa xác bạn gái ở trong nhà hàng ngày,
rồi đặt mua và li bỏ thi tỉnh nạn nhân vào.
Dạng sáng 8 năm tháng 7, Nhi phạm kéo trước và li chứa thi tỉnh nạn nhân bước trong
con hệ các nhà khoảng 20 mát và bỏ chú xuống tỉnh đồng này.
Lần thân dấu vết, cạnh rất nhiều trong bắt sữa thành.
Chí Tây, Chí Hò và ở Trung nhà với thành, cho biết thành vì cân đứng bẩm xin,
cho mẹ và em gái của người này đã ra nước ngoài xí sống.
Nhi phạm hình lạnh, ít sở tiếng với hàng sống xung quanh và xong ở tông trên,
con người chỉ họ ở tông trên.
Tha chỉ tìm thêm và cố gái có quên biết với nhau như không só và thử điểm nào,
ra định cũng chưa biết mặt nạn nhân ra sông.
Hịt, cơ quan công hành đang làm só về trọng của một người khác mi tình yên có liên qua đến của anh mà.